- [Kim] Long before Rosa Parks refused
to move to the back of the bus,
Homer Plessy boarded a
train car in New Orleans
to protest Jim Crow segregation laws.
Plessy was arrested and
convicted in Louisiana
but his test case for
segregated public transportation
reached the Supreme Court in 1896.
This is Kim from Khan Academy
and today we're learning
more about the landmark case
Plessy versus Ferguson which asked
whether separate but equal accommodations
for black and white Americans
violated the 14th Amendment
of the Constitution.
To learn more about this case,
I spoke with two experts.
Jamal Green is the Dwight Professor of Law
and Columbia Law School.
Earl Maltz a Distinguished
Professor of Law
at Rutgers Law School.
So Professor Greene, could
you kinda set the stage
for us in this time period?
After the Civil War, what was the legal
and social status of former slaves?
- [Jamal] Well of course
the Civil War ended in 1865
and it was fought in large
part over the institution
of chattel slavery, so slavery
of, generally speaking,
black or African American slaves.
And right at the end of the Civil War,
the 13th Amendment was passed
and the 13 Amendment basically said that
there shouldn't be any slavery
or involuntary servitude
in the United States.
So the institution of
slavery itself had ended,
but the passage of the 13th Amendment
did not mean that former
slaves had equal rights.
A number of the former
states of the Confederacy,
the generally speaking Southern States,
passed a number of racially
discriminatory laws,
immediately after the end of slavery
that prevented black Americans from
participating in civil society
on equal terms with whites.
For example, laws restricting
the ability of blacks
to enter into and enforce contracts,
restricting the ability
of blacks to own property,
to sit on juries, to vote,
to testify in court, and so forth.
So there were an number of
openly discriminatory laws.
There were also laws that
required blacks to be employed
on pain of having their labor forced.
So ways of essentially reinstituting
the institution of slavery.
- [Kim] And these were
know as the Black Codes.
- [Jamal] Those were known
as the Black Codes, exactly.
- [Earl] In the Reconstruction
Period, between the,
say the late-1860s and the mid-1870s
there was a concerted effort
by the federal government
to improve the social status
and political rights of African Americans.
In 1876, as part of the settlement of the
Presidential election of
1876, the federal government
drew back some, but most of the
so-called the Redeemer Movement
really took off in the 1890s.
I think 1891 is when the
last real effort is made
by the federal government
to have a serious voting rights act
and after that, the South is pretty much
under control of the people who
sympathized with ex-Confederates.
- [Jamal] In both Northern
and Southern States
there was wide spread racial segregation.
So there were laws that
were basically codifying
long existing social practices
of segregated housing,
segregated schools, and
segregated public conveyances
like steamships and rail cars.
But much of that changed in the years
immediately following the Civil War.
Congress passed a number of federal laws
that banned racial discrimination
particularly in
contracting and in housing.
Quite significantly in addition to
the actual federal laws
that Congress passed,
the country passed and
ratified the 14th Amendment.
- [Kim] So I think one
thing that is very hard
for me to understand and
that I'd seen struggle with,
is you have the passage
of the 14th Amendment
and the 15th Amendment in 1868 and 1870
and these are supposed to
guarantee equal protection
and citizenship and voting
rights for African Americans,
specifically men in the 15th Amendment
and then you have Jim Crow.
So how did we get from this
moment after the Civil War
where things really seem
like they're looking up
in terms of African American citizenship
to the system of Jim Crow
that's going to persist
into the 1960s and '70s?
- [Jamal] The Civil
War did not end racism,
it simply ended slavery.
And so you're still
living in a racist society
in which residential
and school segregation
remained both in Southern
States and in Northern States,
now withstanding the
civil rights amendments.
And in Southern States, Reconstruction,
was the process of trying
to bring former slaves
fully into civil society
was enforced by the presence
of federal troops in Southern States
on the theory, the very
well founded theory,
that states that had just go to war
in order to perpetuate
the institution of slavery
were not going to willingly
adopt equal rights
for the former slaves that they
had just been holding in bondage.
And so there was a federal
military occupation
of a number of former Confederate states
for a good decade plus
after the Civil War,
really ending in 1877.
- [Earl] And at that point,
again through the Redeemer Movement,
people who were the white power structure,
most of which had sympathized with
the secessionist movement,
the white power structure
and its successors took power back in the
beginning in the mid-1870s from the,
in the Southern States and
as part of their campaign,
they imposed the Jim Crow system.
- [Jamal] And slavery
was not just about labor,
it was really a system of racial hierarchy
and many in the United
States remained committed
to that system, even
after bondage itself ended
and if you don't have the
political will within the
Northern States, to enforce
the Reconstruction amendments
you had really a retrenchment
of deep racial inequality
within the Southern States,
but not just within the Southern States,
but also within a number
of Northern States as well.
- [Kim] So let's kinda dial into the case
Plessy versus Ferguson.
Who was Homer Plessy
and why did he take
issue with segregation?
- [Earl] Well the law that was at issue
required what was in
theory separate but equal
accommodation of African
Americans and whites
on public transportation.
Homer Plessy objected to it,
because a, the facilities
weren't really equal
and he objected to it because he was
in part because he was
classified as black,
but also in general because
he thought that was demeaning.
Obviously a majority of
members of the Supreme Court
believed that the
Southern States should be,
should have at least some
leeway to establish their,
the system of racial segregation.
- [Jamal] And so Plessy was
in league with the railroad
and with the civil rights organization
that recruited him to set off a case.
So he agreed with the railroad
to board the white area
of the railway car, on a
car going from New Orleans
to a town called Covington
and it was agreed that the
railway would ask him to leave,
he would refuse, and then
he would be arrested.
And once he was arrested,
that would enable him to challenge the law
under which he was arrested
under the Constitution.
The railroads didn't like this law.
They didn't like this law
because they didn't want
to be subject to fines or liability
for not properly
maintaining separate cars.
It was really up to the conductors
to make sure that separate
cars were maintained
and that the conductors
themselves could be fined
by the state for not doing so,
and it could also be fined by passengers
for mistakenly putting
someone in the wrong car.
So the railroads didn't
really wanna be bothered
with this kind of law,
and so this particular
railroad Eastern Railway,
was willing to agree
to set up the situation
to challenge the law.
- [Kim] So Homer Plessy,
he gets on this train
and he challenges this statute.
I believe he sat in a white's only car
and announced that he was African American
and then he was arrested.
So what happened next?
- [Jamal] He's arrested and
then he is eventually charged
with a crime, with a
violation of the statute
and there's a fine associated
with violating the state law.
And his lawyers bring a claim
that the law violates
the federal Constitution.
So initially it goes through
the state courts of Louisiana
and then eventually they
rule against Homer Plessy
and in favor of the law
and then his lawyers appeal the case
to the U.S. Supreme Court.
- [Kim] So how did the court rule?
- [Jamal] In the years leading up to case,
the lawyers for Homer Plessy
were quite concerned about
the composition of the Court
because they weren't
sure if they could count
five votes in favor of black civil rights,
because none of the justices on the Court
were considered to be particularly
friends of black Americans.
- [Earl] And in the civil
rights cases in 1860,
in 1883, excuse me,
the court had already held
that Congress lacked authority
to prohibit segregation
in public accommodations,
which meant that they
viewed public accommodations
as something purely private,
rather than a civil right,
a place that had governmental
right or a quasi public right,
and that's one of the big
distinction between the majority
and the dissent in both
the civil rights cases
and in Plessy versus Ferguson.
The Court ruled, that in fact,
that so long as the state of Louisiana
maintained separate but equal
facilities they could do that.
That that was not prohibited
by the 14th Amendment.
- [Jamal] The Supreme Court
in 1896 rules seven to one
that the Separate Car
Act is constitutional,
so a state is allowed to
segregate it's public conveyances,
including rail cars by race.
The Court denies that the Separate Car Act
violates the 14th Amendment
to the Constitution.
What the Court basically says,
is look, the law says the
railway cars have to be equal,
even if they're separate.
And all the 14th Amendment requires is
that basic equality in civil rights.
- [Earl] John Marshall Harlan
of course dissented from that.
I think that it's important to understand
what was the actual
nature of Harlan's dissent
rather than the way that
it is actually portrayed.
Harlan is famous talking about
the colorblind Constitution,
but he also in fact,
what he says is with
respect to civil rights,
common rights common to all citizens,
I don't have the exactly line before me,
but that the Constitution was
required to be colorblind.
So one of the big distinctions between
the majority and the dissent
is that Harlan does in fact believe
that the right to use
public transportation
counted as a civil right,
which was and therefore was
protected against segregation
by section one of the 14th Amendment.
I wanna make that point because,
it's pretty clear that
Harlan believed, for example,
that maintenance of segregated schools
would be constitutional and it's also true
that Harlan voted for to say that
designation laws were constitutional.
- [Jamal] The dissenting
judge, Justice Harlan,
himself a former supporter of slavery
who changed his views and
eventually became known
as a champion of black civil rights.
So Justice Harlan, the lone dissenter,
one of the only Southern
judges on the court,
but the others were basically Northern,
both Republican and Democrat.
They didn't have strong views about race.
They didn't have unusually
strong views about race
for their time
and they maintained this distinction
between social and civil rights.
It's important to understand
in trying to understand
the context of Plessy versus Ferguson
that the Supreme Court used to distinguish
between what it called civil rights
and what it called social rights.
Civil rights were, basically
rights to participate
in civil society and included rights like
the right to enter into contracts,
the right to buy property,
the right to testify in court.
The Court understood social rights
as something very different from that,
which is really the right
to do all of those things
in the company of people
of a different race.
- [Kim] That's fascinating.
So what was the effect of this ruling
in Plessy versus Ferguson?
- [Earl] There are two ways
that you could look at it,
but until 1954, the effect
of the ruling was to allow,
was to say that the state governments
were allowed to segregate their citizenry
on the basis of race.
That's one way you can look at it.
Now, one of the interesting questions is,
how much difference it would have made,
given the sort of culture
of the Southern States
even if the Court had held
that it was unconstitutional
for the state to formally require
segregation among the races?
That is that there were a
lot of informal pressures
which would have pushed
towards segregation
even if the Court had said that
the statute was unconstitutional.
But will never know that.
So in other words, the question in Plessy
is not whether the federal government
was going to mandate segregation,
but rather whether the federal government
was simply going to leave the states
and their citizenry to their own devices
in determining whether to segregate
their public transportation
and some other thing.
- [Kim] So this concept
of separate but equal,
is I think the most important thing
that comes out of Plessy versus Ferguson
and then later will be at
issue in the 20th Century.
So was separate ever equal
in theory or in practice?
- [Jamal] It was very clear at the time,
and Justice Harlan says so
in his dissenting opinion,
in Plessy that the practice
of separating railway cars
or any number of other public
accommodations by race,
was not designed for the
comfort of black Americans.
It was designed in order to maintain
their social inferiority
through legal institutions.
So once you know longer have
the institution of slavery,
there was a felt need
among many in the South
to maintain the system of social relations
that slavery represented
and that's what Jim Crow was all about.
And everyone knew that's
what Jim Crow was all about.
So Jim Crow was really
kind of in its infancy
when Plessy versus Ferguson was decided.
Laws that prevented blacks from voting
through a number of, through
the literacy requirements
and property requirements and
good character requirements
and so forth, those kinds of laws
were very much in their infancy
at the time Plessy versus
Ferguson was decided
and so the whole system of segregation
is really revving up in the 1890s
and the Court just gives it carte blanche
to continue after that.
And it's important to
remember that as of the 1890s
the Supreme Court had not admitted
to ever having reversed
one of its own decisions.
The lawyers who brought the Plessy case
were quite clear about this.
The assumption was that
once the Court ruled,
it was going to be an awfully long time
before you could get the
Court to reverse itself,
and that's in fact what happened.
So the Court does not reverse
Plessy versus Ferguson
until Brown versus Board
of Education in 1954.
And so you had an almost 60 period
in which practices of
institutionalized segregation
had the blessing of the Supreme Court.
- [Kim] So we've learned that
in Plessy versus Ferguson
the Supreme Court took a narrow view
of the equal protection clause,
ruling that separate
but equal accommodations
for white and black Americans
did not violate the 14th Amendment.
Earl Maltz suggests that
it's difficult to tell
if a different outcome
in Plessy versus Ferguson
would have made much difference
in the actions of Southern
States, if there was no
political will to enforce
integration anyway.
Jamal Greene, by contrast,
reminds us that segregation
was just getting started
at the time of the Plessy case
and this ruling by the Court
legitimized Jim Crow laws
that would continue to
spread for nearly 60 years.
To learn more about
Plessy versus Ferguson,
check out the National
Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on U.S. Government and History.